et les états unis puisent dans leurs
réserves stratégiques de pétrole en
coordination avec d'autres pays
annoncent cet après midi de la maison
blanche objectif tenter de faire baisser
les prix de l'or noir en mettant 50
millions de barils sur le marché les
explications de notre correspondant à
washington
thomas bonnin
la décision de joe biden de puiser dans
les réserves stratégiques américaines de
pétrole est présenté par le locataire de
la maison blanche comme une initiative
majeure qui peut faire la différence et
enfin faire baisser les prix à la pompe
pour les américains on sait que les prix
ont beaucoup augmenté ces dernières
semaines et c'est en réaction à cette
augmentation que joe biden conjointement
avec d'autres pays tels que le royaume
uni le japon ou encore l'inde ont décidé
donc de prendre cette décision pour
tenter de faire baisser le cours du
pétrole sur les marchés financiers une
manoeuvre qui aura un effet seulement à
court terme selon un certain nombre
d'avis de spécialistes financiers c'est
aussi ce que reproche une partie de
l'opposition républicaine à joe biden
écouter la décision du président byden
de puiser dans les réserves stratégiques
américaines ce qui va libérer seulement
l'équivalent de trois jours du pétrole
sur le marché n'est pas une véritable
solution à notre crise énergétique
c'est une ruse politique grossière à
trois jours de thanksgiving les élus
républicains qui reproche plus
généralement la politique énergétique
menée par joe biden qu'ils accusent en
réalité d'être responsables de la
situation actuelle
et puis du côté des démocrates il faut
noter qu'une lettre avait été adressée à
joe biden récemment par certains élus du
parti démocrate pour lui demander d'une
part donc de puiser dans ses réserves
stratégiques américaines mais aussi de
mettre un terme au moins temporairement
aux exportations de pétrole américains
et ce afin de conserver les ressources
pour un usage domestique c'est une
mesure qui n'a pour l'heure pas été
retenu par la maison blanche